hello everyone how you doing has ad
post-lunch feeling kicking in right now
y'all wanting to go to sleep okay I'll
try and keep it light and fun
um so welcome to hey my craft getting
started with the open source home
assistance um how many of you have a
home assistant at home like it looks a
Google um things like that all right
have any of you develop this skill for
it before one person I haven't this'll
be fun
um I had never developed one before I
decided to do or kind of play with this
too so um just skip almost like a
different setup than I'm normally used
to um yeah skip real quick um so kind of
briefly I'm going to talk about the
layout of this talk real quick I'm going
to kind of give you an introduction to
what the device is and kind of how it
works probably won't take too long
because you can know already what it is
I'm guessing um how do you get one you
can also build one so I'll talk about
that really briefly what kind of going
do some skills and how you would develop
some of them for your own if you wanted
to extend this I'll do a few different
example skills and then kind of wrap it
up in the end so so I'm good
cool alright um it's a little bit about
it like we said it's a home assistant
sort of like Alexa Google home all those
um it's entirely open source you can go
on github you can get all the code to
run it and all the codes run all the
skills as well and the speech
recognition is done on the device so
instead of it pushing everything up to
the cloud and then getting a response
back it can actually recognize the text
on the device and then read back the
response on there too and I'll show you
some of that it's really kind of cool um
and then if you choose to opt in you can
actually send stuff to the organization
that runs it so they can kind of improve
some of their services to some of the
pros of this device is that a protect
your privacy it's not backed by a big
company so you don't have to worry about
what they're doing kind of with your
data or if they're spying on you it's
really just all done locally and if you
submit your stuff up to the cloud it's
just kind of kept fairly and honestly
they don't know where it comes from or
anything like that you can see all of
its thinking so I'll show you kind of
how you can get into the logs and see
you know how exactly it's processing all
the different skills how it's
translating your text into you the
different things they can do you can
build it yourself so this is the one I
don't it's made out of Raspberry Pi and
I'll show you that a minute too and it's
free um you know kind of outside of the
cost of the parts for the thank you so
that's really helpful um there's a
couple cons to it and I'll go ahead and
just bring those up front depending on
the device it can be slow if you have
like an older Raspberry Pi it may take a
few more seconds for it to figure out
what you're saying things like that
upgrades are a little slower because
they don't have millions of dollars like
a big tech company would sometimes you
know things take a little longer yet out
the door and some of the newer skills
are slow to come out because it just
doesn't have that huge vacuum yet but
hopefully maybe some of you can start
contributing to the skill set um so if
you want the purchase of Mycroft they
have the mark one now so that was funded
on a Kickstarter and it's a cute little
thing there you can change the size
colors and make its mouth move and
things like that
and it's like about one hundred and
fifty dollars I think they just started
to make a new one that's the market to
you here and has a cool screen and you
can change the different things on it
too if you want to build one yourself
they have a Pycroft which is kind of
what I did here so mine's just a
Raspberry Pi and then this
omnidirectional microphone speaker combo
and that was about like 40 bucks I think
for me you can also download it on Linux
which is kind of what I'm going to show
you here on the computer so it runs a
little bit more efficiently for like
giving a talk on it they also have an
Android package it's not ready deployed
on the store yet so you can I have to
download the code and run it yourself
but they're working on getting that
available and then they're working on a
Windows version
or an Apple version that's not quite out
the door yet so like I said little
slower because it's open source if you
were to get a Raspberry Pi it's kind of
simple you just kind of go there website
where you can get these slides later and
click that link to go straight to the
image you just flash it on a card and
when you plug it in it's already
installed and ready to go so it's gonna
read off a code and then you just go on
the website to pair it and then it's
just activating similarly for Linux kind
of the same thing except you cloned the
Mycroft core repo go into the directory
do the install so I'll just make sure it
has all the packages that need so just
mostly like python things and then you
can either start up or start mycroft all
will child it listen to me oh it's gonna
complain here in a second um forgot to
turn off microphone so all just runs all
of the services in the background and
then debug runs all the services and
then brings up the command line prompt
so you can do the debugging stuff with
it and similarly when you download it
the first time each is parent online on
their website I have the website real
quick that's going to pull it up the
third of my boot probably one do it's in
[Music]
not that one
uh-huh no I'll hold it later so pretty
some think we did already
oh yeah just pairing it up you go to
home dot mycroft that AI and that's kind
of the website of the organization and
it synchronizes settings across multiple
devices if you have them that's the main
part of it you can also tell it to turn
on skills or turn off skills so it's
kind of all done through them but they
don't really track you or anything like
that so it'll read off a six digit code
you just type that in and then you're
just kind of good to go so it's really
easy to set up um so the core package of
it it has a few different components the
first one is an audio playback so that's
kind of the obvious where it just reads
the speech to you they have an open
source one that's pretty good I've been
kind of playing with it it's sounds
really reasonable there's a British
voice that sounds really weird but the
American voice seems so much better
sorry y'all
I'm the message bus so that's the
communication part where it listens to
what you're trying to say it sends a
message to a skill kind of some routing
and things like that
the skill sart's itself so it takes your
texts parses out what it's trying to do
passes that to the particular code and
then gets a response back the voice
capture which actually listens to your
voice and translates it into text that's
also an open-source package but I think
they have a non open-source package you
can switch it to a few months and
finally the enclosure service so when
you run it on Lennox you don't have an
enclosure service but if you got like
the one of the two devices that they
have there would be an enclosure and you
can also build your own and they kind of
give you instructions with that on the
website so really quickly how do we make
a skill for it
so we need to identify the intent of it
so what do you want to do so for
instance you want it to tell you what
the weather is do you want it to look up
the stock price quote things like that
and then from there determine what words
it wants to respond to you so if you're
looking for something like the weather
you might say what's the weather today
but you would generally want to look for
like weather today but kind of like what
is
sort of kind of optional so you can kind
of build this sort of hierarchy of
importance of words and then tell it you
know you have to have these these are
nice to haves if you will I mean you can
also set it up for different languages
too so if you're in English look for
these words if you're in French look for
these words and then from there you'd
write the code to produce that
particular spoken response and that kind
of won't go into a couple definitions
that they use throughout the product
which will make a little bit more sense
when we get into some of the code so the
work word is the words that you would
use to kind of turn it on so in this
case by default
it's hey Mycroft we can change that and
they have different options on the
website too the utterance is after
you've woken it what you say after that
so like what's the weather today would
be in the utterance from there that gets
passed to the intent engines where you
know tries to parse out the words and
then you build the intense just do
different things and then finally you
return a dialog object and the dialogue
is just whatever it speaks back so you
can kind of build that up or just return
some predefined ones maybe I could show
off some of those real quick
all right um since the debug window hey
where'd you go my windows from not
working for me your name's variance um
maximize there we go okay so when you
run the debug it pulls up this interface
and this is actually a really nice
interface that the top part is all the
logs so you can kind of see what it's
doing how it's processing when it
reloads some skills things like that and
then the bottom part had started
transcribing me apparently is where it's
listening for input so many times I hear
something or says something it's shown
down there in the history and then you
see a microphone level I have the
microphone turned off so it's kind of
getting a little bit of small residual
noise if I turned it back on you can see
it's kind of picking up some more stuff
around here so um for a demo
hey Mycroft hey Mycroft hello world
I think it's still waking up maybe I
started I think it's still trying to
process that last one everybody loves
like demos right so it's also as a
floating skills it's kind of nice to see
what it's loading if you have an error
in your skill the error would usually
show up in this log to UM maximize that
one although I didn't stay open there is
an error I haven't quite figured out
what that's specifically on my machine
but says training complete so that's
when you know it's loaded up all the
intense that it's going to do um hey my
craft hello world hey you - hey my craft
hey my craft what's the weather today
it's currently shower rain and two
degrees Celsius today's forecast is for
a high of two and a low of one so you
can kind of see the back-and-forth down
there at the bottom but you can also see
where you know what heard the wake word
it starts recording detected that I
heard the wake words and then looks for
a specific utterance that you said so
from there it knows where to pass it
around well that's fun that looks like a
Internet I heard that showed up um so
that's kind of the basic idea you can do
a bunch of other things like set alarms
or look up stock prices or there's a
couple different games that you can
download that on there so pretty cool
but I also like that you can kind of see
how it works cuz I'm always one of those
that likes to tinker with things
no it just kind of worked right out of
the box that's pretty nice
okay so for a skill there's a certain
lay out how the code works the first
repo is the core repository for my cross
so you you know like I've shown you
download that so it could work in Linux
there's also a docker image of it and if
you're really bold you could try and get
it working on a different system and
then the skills repo and that's where
literally all the different skills are
at um that's good to show that off to
I'm also using a new computer I haven't
used before so this a bit thing yep here
you go that's right now I can't drag
this actually not just yet so since the
core repo this has all the code for how
the thing itself works I can't type
either apparent y'all are watching me
fumble right after lunch maybe this will
be entertainment skills there yeah um
each one of these different skills is a
sub module to a different repo so what
you do is you'd make a repo of chester
skill and then when you're ready to
submit it you would PR it against theirs
by adding a sub module
um and that's how that works so I was
gonna go into my personal skills that I
made which I'm not super fancy good
there we go okay so go back to this um
okay yeah there's that too
so within a particular skill itself
there's a few different directories that
kind of have to be there in structured
in a certain way the first ones the
dialogues so those are what's going to
respond back and these are usually I'm
gonna call them canned phrases so
phrases it would definitely say in a
particular way so in this case if you
had a hello world the dialogue in
English would be you know inside that
hello dot world dialogue cloud and you
can do more than one phrase so I can
just pick a different one so it sounds a
little bit more conversational um the
vocab it's what it's listening for so in
this case hello dot world dot PLC would
have the different words that would be
listening for to trigger this hello
world so in case hello world or maybe
like hi world or just hello could work
and then there's also a readme file and
that's just is kind of like metadata
about the skill and it thought Pi is
pretty much for the bulk of your code
we'll go and I'll show those in a bit
and then requirements dot SH is if you
have to have any like operating system
requirements to make this thing work and
their requirements txt is if you have
any Python packages you need to make
this thing work okay so real quick I
want take a moment if a few of you want
to tweet something real quick to Mycroft
at NDC I'm gonna start and see if I can
get this skill to work so I'm just gonna
have it read hashtags in a bit please
nothing dirty this is getting recorded
alright so I'm gonna go into code I have
here we go
um so the first go that it didn't
actually end up loading but it still
works I was testing it earlier um is
what I'm calling the welcome to NBC
London one so I was gonna have it just
you know like hi can you welcome the
group and it was going to say in
response like hello welcome to in DC so
kind of a simple sort of hello world
sort of thing so this is the init that
PI file at the top you have to do a
couple of things to include the core
skills in the intent builder and then
you just make a class for whatever your
skilling this in this case welcome in DC
London and then you have to have that
create skills that just tells it to add
the skill into the set um and then
intent handler there's two ways to do it
once an intent builder and I think
that's kind of their older way to do it
so we're not going to actually build one
with us today but require means look for
this vocab file and include it so it's
gonna look for that welcome in DC that
vo C file and when it sees that get
triggered then it's going to run this
intent function here and literally all
it's just going to say is speak this
dialogue from the Welcome and DC file so
welcome in DC dialogue there's also just
a speak function and that would just be
you have a text and if it just read it
so speak that dialogue looks at it from
the file there's metal secure see I have
two different setups here's
should try this on a projector first
brothers okay um it's in here I just
have a few different things to listen
for so can you welcome the audience you
know welcome our audience so it would
listen for any of these and trying to
trigger off of that and they're in
response it would speak from this file
so I just had literally the one thing to
say from there so if you have more than
one line in here with just pick one by
random and read it out so it could kind
of sound different each time and double
check I don't think it was actually
working that we'll see hey my craft hey
my craft welcome the audience I don't
understand um I didn't load incorrectly
for some reason I think um the skill
name on it changed and so it wasn't
living in but um it works I swear so
that's the first skill it's not really
super exciting the second skill I had is
a little bit more exciting so that was
going to read the hashtags there um so
we're yeah so in here I had to tell it
to add a Python Twitter package so that
way you can contact the Twitter API to
do it and then down here in the code we
have a little bit more complicated stuff
so we import the Twitter package on top
of everything else so I'm gonna make a
new class called rehash tag inherits
from my craft skill and then the handler
is going to look for a read hash tag
from the vocab and that's just I think
it literally it just reads the hash tag
or list the hash tags
so anything like that I decided not to
give you all my Twitter keys sorry but
so we can make a quick Twitter
connection and then as I add the logger
info it will actually show up in that
debug screen so you can have gotten info
about debug dot error different things
like that I kind of verify that the
credentials work look up the user ID
just to make sure it's working from here
I can get a search for that hashtag so
I'm a tweet out on it no hopefully oh
you can catch up so for each one of the
tweets it gets so I say just get like
five of them I kind of build up this
text that it's going to read out it's
just like username said blah blah blah
are using tweeted blah blah blah and
then gonna actually like speak literally
here's the last five tweets with the
hashtag mycroft at in DC and then speak
that text that we just built up from
there so we can try this real quick hey
Mycroft hey Mycroft hey Mycroft there we
go a read hashtag
here of the last five tweets with the
hesitant Mycroft nc microcode tweeted my
crafts and test test as la Fentress
tweeted a geek evil sir my craft and in
London tank Thomas tweeted had Mycroft
my craft and in London and stack o-67
v-neck J Lucifer drone tweeted what is
your favorite color my craft and purple
a little bit more reliable than the
first kill apparently so I mean still
pretty simple to use um you know really
wasn't a ton of code the bulk of it was
just like setting up all the Twitter
stuff to get it to work and you could do
this for like to-do list managers if you
wanted to add
you know items to your list or remove
them you know check them off the stack
and then my third skill I want to just
show off is a little bit fancier um I
think I want to show it off first before
um I think there's a bit of an echo
which is why it's having all trouble
understanding me hey my craft
hey Mycroft a little more yeah I think
it's getting some background noise hey
my craft
hey Mycroft actually wonder if I could
use this microphone depth a little
better
what's your favorite color whoever
tweeted that orange oh it's a good car
anyone else have a favorite color
Erica hey Mycroft there we go
hello world just a big hello okay cool
sir we're working okay here's the third
skill and what I hope will be more
entertaining
okay Mycroft hey Mycroft knock knock
who's there a broken pencil
a broken pencil ooh never mind
it's pointless you are so hilarious
I think the monotony of it really helps
don't you which is pretty much how my
friends respond to me anyway Haley
yeah sure that was funny Oh uh-huh let's
try that one knock knock oh hey Mycroft
knock knock who's there
little old lady little old lady who I
didn't know you could yodel
[Music]
it's made worse by how long this text
that is the best joke I've heard all day
okay that was terrible anyway
Oh but well the things you notice was I
could carry on a conversation with it it
didn't have to be just a call in
response and then it was done so it
actually didn't need me to keep saying
like hey Mycroft you know Talgo who hey
Mycroft no silly cows go Moo so that
won't talk a little bit more work to do
but it still was relatively easy to do
it so I kind of made a new skill here
for doc Doc's skill I made kind of a
helper function here to just say if I'm
passing it a dialogue get a response
from me and return that back as text so
dialogue would be an object to send to
it one of the dialogue files and then
return response would just give me the
text back from that um so that's how I
did the back-and-forth
so with this intent handler I looked in
the knock-knock file for you know the
text to listen to you in this case just
literally knock-knock
so when I said hey Mike Ralph
knock-knock you know it would say who's
there in response get me to say
something after that and then kind of do
the same thing again listen for what I
said repeat that back to me that's what
the now and here is cousin like I don't
know what it is and then get down who
tutors bond back and then literally it's
just whatever I said after that it would
just read something from the last file
so here we had multiple dialogues that I
could say um knocked out who's there
blah blah blah blah blah blah who and
then from here it would read one of the
different random responses um including
the best joke gets hurt all day which I
don't think it's heard that many jokes
but you know makes me feel good telling
silly jokes hurt roomful of strangers
and just for fun I threw in bingo so I
can actually say like ding-dong who's
there and it would still can you do the
same thing each time and you know it's
recording once you hear that you do sort
of noise so you can so if you try to
talk too fast it won't pick up
everything so it's just one of the
things you gotta kind of pay attention
to but so just in the end you have to
have that create skill function at the
end you just add this to the whole set
so it's generally pretty easy to do this
you can build kind of more complicated
things with this to up here you see
there's a dot require so it has to hear
something from that file but you can
also do dot optional so you can do
something like an optional phrase or
required phrase and then like another
optional or you can do them in kind of
any combination you want to sort of
build up a kind of thing it's listening
for and then if you switch different
languages you can build different sub
directories in here for you know I'm
doing US English we could do French and
other things too so it can respond in a
bunch of different languages too and
there's a whole bunch of other different
intents in there too you and there's a
lot of examples on the website but I
didn't want to go into some of the
really really detailed ones because that
would mean this code would be pages and
pages and pages long it's kind of hard
to parse out interesting kind of any
questions so far
well is that sorry how would I install
it
oh good question um so I cloned the
skills repo so I have the github repo in
one directory where it's installed it's
skills from Mycroft that a s website is
/op slash Mike yeah Sascha ops Mike Ross
skills so what I did was I just linked
my skill folder from my github repo into
that one so as I made changes it just
propagated in there and it reloaded
instantly um so I mean I can try to do
that maybe really simple ones and try to
read it real quick um so if I didn't
want let's just um don't you just did
one in a hit save um it should notice oh
because I didn't want you all seen my
keys so I didn't edit that I can open
the actual skills I think I have
[Music]
Oh where's it hurt you she's like the
knocked object so if I did um let's see
I can't think of a thing to change on
here um like I don't know if I want to
add another like laughs um and save it
um it should take effect almost
instantly let's just make every joke
absolutely terrible nothing's funny at
all um she'll see as I made a change
skill knock knock tried to reload
so hopefully almost instantly it should
kick in
hey Mycroft hey Mycroft knock knock
who's there H who's there
ooh um that show government I was going
to say edge at you bless you yeah I
think it drives three times in very
often that's not funny at all so if I
can't hear you know it'll keep trying to
do the conversation and you can build in
stop functions if you're saying like
reading the news um you know it's
reading a big paragraph of different
things you can tell it to stop and it
will
there's a stop function built into it so
you can actually stop a skill in the
middle of it's doing something so um I
think that wraps back to the question it
rose it stored so I chopped up my craft
slash skills and it will reload if it's
in that directory as you make changes
then somebody else have a question
um oh so if you wanted to save the
letters like say by the way you can also
type in things if you don't feel like
talking all the time yeah so you have to
kind of a beat yeah so you kind of have
to phonetically think through things
like I think it was trying to read the
Mycroft in DC is one big word
even though really that's not how we
would purse a stag out but so if you
were to do something like that you might
have to actually say like okay purse out
the capital letters and add spaces in
there take off the pound and add in hash
tag to do things like that then was
there a question in the back yeah
that's a good question
um yes so I think it's um oh shoot our
money mother um there's an open source
package that does the speech recognition
so it hears the syllables and then tries
to parse them together as words it knows
so I think there's an English language
dictionary in there somewhere but
sometimes I have told it things and it's
recognized like names and stuff too so I
don't know if it necessarily another how
it works it's a little above my pay
grade I think but they do have a
different non like a proprietary
text-to-speech engine you can use to you
can go into the settings and swap it out
is it that one yeah close out um you can
go in here you can log in real quick
[Music]
also conference Wi-Fi right yeah because
it does the synchronization with the
website you do have to make an account
on there
[Music]
so here Jess is the name of my base one
here and then Lennox is the name of this
one if I make a change to like my
location it will update on both at the
same time same for like time zones
things like that so I'm based out of the
eastern in of the US so when I moved
here all the times are awful the weather
was off things like that so I went into
settings and like I can change this ones
location I said you know I was in
Pittsburgh but this one I changed to
London Westminster so it synchronizes
through that if you go into kind of
where it really kind of meets the
synchronization as if you go in here to
the kind of skills library and pick that
you want another one to add well I'm not
saying it I'm like I know I have some of
those installed
yeah so as you add or remove it goes to
all of your devices and adds them or
removes them so basically it's just kind
of a synchronization point it's not
storing your sound files or anything
like that or actually it's not storing
your searches either it's just kind of a
small synchronization point in between
all of your devices so if you had like
one in your living room and your dining
room in your bedroom I can do that and
that's kind of also where the log file
comes in nice you can see what it's
doing it will always tell you when it's
transmitting something up or when you
make a change and it synchronizes back
down so if I'm in here and I I can go
back to settings so it was reading the
temperature in Celsius if I had a change
here let's go to Fahrenheit here within
hopefully a minute it should show you
that it's received a notification to
update no hopefully not that one yeah
I'll wake up oh I think it's hearing
wake up and Oh turn the microphone off
so oh yeah there it is configuration
skill remote configuration applied so it
got those new settings and it applied
them here past that it doesn't really do
any communication there's a you can opt
into the open data set or says like it
will record like your wake words and
some of your things and that's just to
make sure they're text-to-speech or
voice our conditions thing can get
improved so they have a thing up here
you can go to tagging if you feel like
doing it precise that's something that
so these people have donated their
voices to this project and so you see
so it heard that and it's ended up to
the cloud and saying was that
hey Mycroft or was that something close
to hey my craft or is that not anything
close to a Minecraft and I think that
was just background noise so you can
train it a little better with that and
one of the things they're working on is
not that um deep search which is a
mozilla-based kind of cloud engine so
Mozilla's pretty privacy focused so this
would be if you choose to opt into doing
deep search it would send your things up
to the cloud and the zola would process
it and come back but it's still not
tagged to you personally it's just kind
of a setup to figure out what it is and
send it back so that helps a lot with
different accents that stuff hasn't been
trained on yet any other questions so
far yeah um when you disconnect from the
internet it complains because every so
often it tries to contact home base just
to make sure there's no changes to
settings and stuff and it will say it
lost Internet but things like looking up
the weather and all those do you require
the internet so it kind of mostly loses
its feel for what it's trying to do just
because it can't look up queries and
stuff either and it does have tie-ins
like Wikipedia and Wolfram Alpha tooth
you can give it you know other different
types of things to look up yeah well
those but ones like what time is it
it doesn't need to actually go online to
do those so we probably do this locally
but not it was still kind of complaining
when it goes offline
all right guess we're kind of getting
close to time second
oh we're not close to time but also
gonna wrap up Oh
so hopefully being in Python you noticed
it's pretty easy to kind of get yeah and
if he did make a skill and you wanted to
send it up to everybody he thought
everybody could use it put your skill
inside of a repo on github clone their
skills repo add yours as a sub module to
theirs and then do a PR and they have a
list on their website of make sure these
things are kind of in order before
you've submitted and then they'll
probably approve it and throw it up on
the skill store for everybody to get
it's kind of in the end it's an
open-source homeless is it it's really
kind of cool I think all of the speech
recognition and voice output is all done
locally on the device and not thrown up
in the cloud
everything is really easily done in
Python I think and there's a really good
you know way of thinking it easy to kind
of parse out language which is really
kind of a hard thing to do so I think
they have a pretty good set up there my
name is sarah with e i'm geeky girl
Sarah on Twitter and if you have any
questions I'll throw the slides up in a
bit I don't think they're on the website
yet but I'll get them up after this talk
and if you want to come up here and play
with the device and kind of see that
output and everything you're more than
welcome to you so thank you for coming
[Applause]